[Music]
people share stories with me all the
time that they've had an ukulele sitting
in their closet for years and years and
years and they've never taken it out
so take that ukulele out of the closet
let's play some music
i started playing the ukulele when i was
four years old i remember the first time
i picked it up and played it i was just
overwhelmed with this joy
till this day every time i pick up my
ukulele and play i mean it's that same
joy there's something about this
instrument that brings out this
childlike quality
in everyone and who doesn't want to feel
like a kid again right
and i promise you if you have a couple
fingers to spare
and you know how to count you will learn
how to play this instrument
oh that sounds so good i love that
the beautiful thing about the ukulele
lies in its simplicity
you have four strings you have two
octaves to work with and that's it
just take your finger and put it in the
bottom left hand corner like that
you know and that's your first chord
it's a c7 chord
and then all you do is you jump up a
string and that's your f chord
and with that you can play hundreds of
songs
i mean literally hundreds of songs
utilizing a tremolo technique can be
difficult but it can give you that
illusion of the note
sustaining over a chord or for a
duration of time
there's a magical thing that happens
when you're holding an instrument and
connecting with it and making a sound
that's like therapy for me
music i think has the power to truly
shape who we are
and i hope that people will discover
through this master class that the
ukulele is not just
a tool to make music but it's something
that
can be life-changing
aloha i'm jake shimobukuro and this
is my master class
[Music]
you